le premier responsable de cette crise
ici à val d'or c'est le premier ministre
du québec
bonsoir monsieur k oui bonsoir monsieur
roy monsieur picard expliquez moi je
vous dit
la faute de ce malaise de ce noeud de
ces problèmes de relation de cette
violence possiblement policière la faute
incombe au premier ministre du québec
expliquez moi seul but dresser la
responsabilité qui incombe au premier
ministre du québec et je pense que c'est
aussi en réponse à ce que j'appellerais
peut-être
une indifférence totale par rapport à la
crise la crise qui sévit ici à valdes
ans et qui met non seulement les
autorités de part et d'autre côté
premières nations et des élus municipaux
par exemple un peu en opposition mais
c'est sa touche une société dans son
ensemble et je pense que ça c'est
important de leur canne de leur
reconnaître je lisais un peu plus tôt
que monsieur prudhomme semble pas être
du même avis de la sûreté du québec
semble pas mettre avis que ledit
qualifie pour sa de crise alors que ce
que vivent les élus sont c'est autre
chose
donc vous dites cette crise là n'est pas
assez prise au sérieux à québec
qu'est ce que vous voudriez bon là vous
voulez une rencontre maintenant avec le
premier ministre mais qu'est ce que vous
voudriez comme geste très concrets dans
les 24 48 72 prochaines heures
c'est qu'il y ait une reconnaissance que
je 0 on est devant une situation qui a
pas de précédent
je pense que ça puisse aller aussi loin
que des des révélations comme celle
qu'on a entendues dans l'émission
enquête juste 10 derni je pense que tout
le monde reconnaîtra alors que ça crée
une onde de choc non seulement à
l'intérieur de nos communautés mais
aussi à l'extérieur de nos communautés
et je veux aussi insister sur le fait
que ça demande une intervention
immédiate parce que il ya non seulement
les personnes qui ont procédé ou
dénonciation mais il y aussi le
potentiel d'autres personnes qui procède
de la même façon et
avec la ligne de la spvm si je comprends
bien donc on a besoin d'être aussi dont
on a besoin de ressources pour répondre
à potentiellement une vague de personnes
qui vont comme leur soeur de la semaine
dernière vont s'ouvrir le regard sur la
relation je dirais inquiétante entre nos
communautés leurs membres et la sûreté
du québec il ya cette enquête de la
police de montréal d'abord faites vous
confiance à la police de montréal pour
inquiéter sur des collègues la sqv octet
je pense que le consensus selon la
discussion que nous avons eue
aujourd'hui c'est que la confiance n'est
pas au rendez vous un corps de police
qui enquête sur un autre corps de police
encore une fois mais est ce que par
exemple on peut envisager que ce soit
entre les mains de la grc
mais en même temps et tout le monde
semblait d'accord là dessus il est
important que nous soyons partie
prenante du processus nous avons nous
aussi que vous voulez les policiers qui
ont certains combats qui ont certaines
compétences en matière de banque est et
ce qu'on voudrait aussi que ce soit
considérée donc vous voulez une
rencontre en haut lieu pour discuter du
des meilleur chemin à prendre et pas
nécessairement toutes les discussions si
on met il ya cette enquête d'un côté ses
gestes ses allégations qui ont choqué
tout le québec le jeudi soir on a vu ces
témoignages de ces femmes autochtones
ça révèle aussi un climat de violence un
climat de pauvreté des problématique
d'alcool de drogue ça la responsabilité
la vôtre les chefs d'autochtones les
communautés autochtones qu'elle est elle
vécue il ya deux choses à dire là-dessus
d'abord on a constaté on en n'est pas du
tout surpris qu'il ya un mouvement qui
vise à nous retourner la balle dans
notre camp comme leader autochtone et
sort c'est quelque chose qui nous
surprend pas de la part de certains de
vos collègues dans différents médias
c'est ce qu'on voit si ce qu'on lit
maintenant ceci étant dit et
les chefs se sont prononcés là dessus
aujourd'hui on reconnaît que le climat
social au sein de nos communautés et est
loin de faire est loin de refléter
l'idéal de ce qu'on souhaiterait comme
société et c'est à dire collègues et
responsables nous avons dit aujourd'hui
que hi viol les lionnes
il ya de quoi faire pour redresser la
situation mais en même temps ceci étant
dit si on accepte la responsabilité
il faut aussi que quelque part on
accepte la responsabilité qu'on y est on
ne peut pas être tout seul à changer les
choses parce qu'on le dit souvent on va
leur dire on n'a pas les ressources
nécessaires pour procéder à ce vaste
chantier
je vous laisse aller me supplie car j'ai
le temps filmé par exemple pour être
très concret pour les gens c'est quand
même incroyable qu'à val-d'or
il n'y ait pas de ressources en pleine
nuit pour aider des gens qui sont qui
sortent des bars qui ne savent pas où
aller
ay manquent cruellement de ressources
pour les autochtones mais aussi pour
pour les blancs house et pas que les
autochtones qui vivent ces réalités là
il ya des problèmes très coquet mais
c'est un constat qu'on fait
malheureusement pour un certain
saint-urbain à l'échelle du québec
et quand je parle de ressources je parle
évidemment de ses escales de ces
exemples long et on est à ossen d'amitié
aujourd'hui c'est un sens d'amitié qui
qui et puis ces ressources humaines pour
ce type d'intervention l'autre donc
c'est aussi une évaluation que nous
aurons enfin juste les picards merci
chef de l'assemblée des premières
nations du québec et du labrador merci
d'avoir été avec nous quelques minutes
vous venez tout juste de sortir de cette
conférence de presse on va suivre ce qui
se passe les prochaines heures
les prochaines journées et j'espère les
prochains mois aussi que ça ne tombera
pas dans l'oubli tout ça il ne faut pas
que la poussette ont trouvé d'armé faire
merci merci m supplique à